from providing us with GPS directions to
TV and radio broadcasts the satellites
orbiting the Earth serve a variety of
functions but not like the one that's
about to be launched Kenneth Craig has
the story this November a SpaceX Falcon
9 rocket will deliver 70 satellites into
Earth's orbit including one that comes
not from a laboratory but from the
Nevada Museum of Art it's called orbital
reflector and it's the latest work by
artist Trevor Paglen the point of
working on orbital reflector was to try
to imagine a different kind of
infrastructure could we imagine making a
satellite that's the exact opposite of
every other satellite this satellite
balloon will unravel and expand once in
space going from a package the size of a
shoebox to a diamond sculpture the size
of two school buses for me it was
important to create a kind of catalyst
for people to go out and to look at the
sky and think about the politics of
space and public space after working on
a previous project Paglen began to see a
disturbing trend the time has come to
establish the United States space force
and I was noticing that there was a kind
of military occupation of space that had
been in place for a long time I started
to think about how space might be
different Paglen and the Nevada Museum
of Art assembled a team that brought
experts in from unconventional fields
it's a large scale project with a lot of
moving components to it viewable to the
naked eye orbital reflector will circle
the planet several times before dropping
back into the Earth's atmosphere and
burn
away but firts three months in space it
may just become the most widely viewed
artwork of all time we look at the sky
and try to figure out what our destiny
might be or what our past might be or
what the present might be for me the
project is really just an opportunity to
ask those big questions for CBS this
morning Saturday Kenneth Craig New York
it's so cool yeah I can't wait to see